i am here with osman says buckshank the
rookie out of stanford university
who is undoubtedly the mvp of today's
game
with an interception that he runs back
for a touchdown in the last 30 seconds
of the contest
osmotes can you walk us through what
happened on that last play it was
amazing yeah we knew we had to go out
there
give 100 we executed it just went our
way today
and was the quarterback giving you any
clues uh today oz uh
it looked like you knew that ball was
gonna be there what was happening knew
we wanted to
have some fun you know execute play one
quarter at a time give a hundred percent
okay okay you know let's just let's talk
about last week's game
uh uh you guys lost a heartbreaker give
me your state of mind
then versus now i wanted to do
play-by-play give it a 100
execution wise execute okay
you know i'm going to ask you something
completely different that's not about
football look at me oz just look at me
saying i'm going to ask you a question
right here that a boy so you and your
wife recently had
right here stay with me you and your
wife recently had twins okay
how does it feel to be a new dad you
know we wanted to stay as a team
execute give a hundred percent play by
play okay you know what
i'm just i'm just gonna i'm gonna do a
little test right now
uh hey oz how did you get to the game
today they're a good team
great team 100 yep
and what you have for dinner last night
100 of 100 yeah you're dead of course
100
or whatever 100 was you know what
can you just do me a favor and tell me
one specific thing like just
one actual original observation that you
had
about today's game the game that you won
almost single-handedly do you think that
you could do that oz
oh 100 oh god damn it